true still [ __ ] bad all right what do
you got hey guys our band ugly smile is
making a podcast intro for your podcast
yeah good fans so we can uh
take it if you want to roast us whatever
you guys can play it and use on the pod
if you uh want we won't sue you our band
is called ugly smiths and we're based
smile
smile sorry and we're based out of
atlanta georgia i might need [ __ ]
glasses
oh look at this that's a cool photo in
front of the the abandoned airplane i
like that where's scooby
yeah where's leonard
[Music]
a little too skinner
birthing and norman's talking [ __ ] about
oh
this
[Music]
is feeling dangerous
[Music]
we might be getting a new theme song i
got chills from that that was great i
loved it they had a i don't know if you
know built the spill
a ban they remind me of that which is
also a funny thing with drinking built
to spill but yeah good stuff ugly smile
out of atlanta that was some real uh
some real rock there oh that's the
lyrics
sunday's the day for my next bender a
bit a peeve a wreck
you know the beard jew is close i've had
a little too much bourbon and norman's
talking [ __ ] about the [ __ ] pope
and i get down in the same way upon the
roof like a cop's coming and naked sam
ul is feeling dangerous oh samuel l
not to lunch in new orleans i get down
the same way we might be drunk all right
cool that's great i like it i'm saying
something more jazzy but i do like it i
do too it cooks it really pops well done
i just got the scooby joke now oh yeah
the van the mystery machine yeah that's
pretty good hey i'm trying and the one
on the right looks like uh trans
delilah or whatever her name was velma
thelma thank you
all right that would have worked if i
got the name right
i'm hopped up on this smile machine or
shine water it's just pretty good very
good very good i'm feeling frisky is
that the last of it all right well we
love you guys keep being honest that we
might be drunk pod at gmail.com leave us
a review you're the best uh keep
listening tell your friends
see you hell yeah keep sending us [ __ ] i
love the smile gotham studios you know
it yeah you got that right
and how's the beacon looking oh we're
close whoa i think we're gonna sell it
out folks oh yeah definitely
we might be sold out thanks a lot
keep on keep it
[Music]
on a little too much burping and
norman's talking [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
post and i get down in the same way
up on the roof like a cop's coming and
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we might
be
true
[Music]